I'm going to be speaking with Tolia Lavan,
who is author of the book Culture War Lords
My Journey into the Dark Web of White Supremacy.
Tolia, great to have you on.
I appreciate your time.
Thank you.
I appreciate you having me on.
So you did something very interesting, which
is you and Ben potentially harrowing, which
is you jumped into some of the dark recesses
of the Internet that I will often mention,
but recommend my audience not dove into.
And this includes white supremacy, anti-Semitism
and all sorts of different areas.
Talk a little bit about why you did this and
sort of how you dipped your toes into this
pool to begin with.
Yes, so I'm a Jewish woman and I've been writing
about the far right for a few years before
the book even came out.
And with that came a response from the white
supremacist white power community.
And my reaction to various waves of harassment
that were vehemently misogynistic, vehemently
anti-Semitic was essentially to.
Instead of kind of curling up and shrinking
back and stop talking was to dove deeper,
I wanted to see who these people were, where
they were coming from, how they were getting
to my Twitter feed.
And, you know, it was sort of a situation
where the abyss was looking at me and I decided
to gaze back and drag what I saw back out
into the light.
So what did you find about the source of many
of the the sort of hateful and trolling messages
that you were getting?
So I decided to take a broad view and look
at both.
The development of the contemporary white
power movement and what it looks like, how
it manifests and where they congregate, so
I spent a lot of time looking at particularly
an encrypted chat app called Telegram and
which has like very strong free speech protections
and sort of never bandz content, really.
So it's become kind of a thriving ground for
white supremacists to particularly in twenty
nineteen, faced some Banning's from mainstream
social media like Facebook and Twitter.
And so that's where I spent a lot of my book
research looking into.
And I found a lot of different tendencies
in communities of interest within the white
power movement that I spend the book, Culture
Warlords Exploring.
Did you talk a little bit about how you existed
in some of these spaces?
I mean, did you develop a character or a series
of characters, alter egos that that you kind
of took on?
Yeah, so I didn't actually set out to write
a gonzo journalism book, it's just that when
you're a Jewish woman and when you've been
kind of an outspoken antifascist for years,
it's hard to get in the front door.
People who are white supremacists won't get
you an interview.
You know, I am.
One of my earlier attempts was to try and
get into.
There's a sort of.
Powerlifting based white supremacist pagan
cult that that has these solstice celebrations
and I tried to get in just as a reporter and
much later one of the guys I was talking to
was like, oh, we would never let a Jew in
anyway.
So, you know, it was hard to get in the front
door, but and so as a result, I found myself
sort of having to get a little creative and
find these back door roots.
And that included making sock puppets, sock
puppet accounts to just kind of squat and
listen and in some other cases, having to
be a little more proactive and inventing kind
of identities from whole cloth in order to
get into more private chats.
And in one case, I infiltrated a white supremacist
dating site, white dot net, with the whole
character who didn't look like me or have
my background as kind of a course Brooklyn
Jew.
And I got these forlorn white supremacists
looking for love to write love letters to
their ideal white wife and send them to me.
And I printed them in the book and it was
sort of a car crash between Nicholas Sparks
and Mein Kampf.
Did you make any of what you would consider
to be friends during this process?
No, I mean, it's not generally my.
My practice to make friends with people who
want me dead, right, but within my character,
I mean, I had.
I was I tried not to be that active and infiltrator,
you know what I mean?
You don't want to be the one amping up the
stochastic terror.
You want to say just enough to pass and remain
in the room.
But in one particular event, there was sort
of a.
And may fight being organized between pagan
white supremacists and Christian white supremacists
to support the presidential run of a white
nationalist Satanist.
And so I got deeply involved in the planning
chat's for that group and wound up talking
pretty extensively to one Christian extremist
and telling him all about how his fascist
love of Christ had saved my life.
Just funny things to have to do from my apartment
in Brooklyn as far as I'm interested in this
religious component.
In your experience kind of weaving your way
through these communities, you know, we know
about the Christian roots of the KKK as an
example, but at the same time, there are many
people who get pulled into white nationalism
and white supremacy who are not particularly
religious.
How relevant was religion, would you say,
in these different enclaves?
Well, the group that I was studying primarily
were sort of these radicalized white power
guys, right?
We know that within the mainline sort of MAGGA
movement, which has its fascistic undertones,
religion plays quite a large role.
This idea that Trump is selected by God and
we must fight for him and everyone else is
of Satan.
The group that I was speaking to tended to
skew younger.
We're a little more disaffected with religion,
but what they really took from religion in
the case of the Christian white supremacists,
there was this absolute fixation on the Crusades
as kind of a lost cause, this battle between
noble white warriors and swarthy interlopers
that they kind of interposed onto contemporary
anti-immigrant anti-Muslim dialog.
So it was kind of like them viewing themselves
as crusaders and flying the Templar Crossette
racist realities.
In the case of pagan white supremacists, heathen
white supremacists, you have this fixation
on Vikings, this idea of white manliness,
and the idea of the Norse pantheon as an indigenous,
white European religion.
And one of the things that sort of.
Surprised and tickled me was that many heathen
white supremacists are drawn to the worship
of the Norse pantheon by the idea that Christianity
was started by a Jew and is thus tainted by
the Jewish taint forever.
And so you can literally be Jesus Christ.
And that's not enough for some anti-Semite,
which was sort of a funny discovery to make
via the people you came across.
What portion did you get this?
I mean, this is it could be just difficult
to tell.
But did you get a sense of what portion would
be willing to sort of go and actually take
violence into their own hands in the real
world versus how many of them are sort of
existing in these online spaces?
And that's as far as they're willing to go.
So when I tallied up the telegram groups I
was involved in and of course that's not the
most scientific measure, but I joined between
ninety and a hundred of these chats and collectively
they had tens of thousands of members.
Sure.
And one of the big problems facing researchers
and journalists in this area is that it's
quite simply very hard to tell which young
man spewing violent and genocidal rhetoric
is going to be the one that snaps.
So, you know, I have a close friend who is
an anti fascist and who was several times
threatened directly by Robert Bowers, who
went on to allegedly shoot 11 Jews in the
Tree of Life synagogue.
And it's just very hard to tell.
It's hard to tell when you're looking at the
sea of essentially stochastic terror, this
sort of perpetual motion machine towards radicalization
and violence.
Who is going to be the one to snap?
And that's why I talk about how the importance
isn't necessarily the raw numbers.
Yeah, but about the tenor of the conversation.
And when you are marinating in stochastic
terror, marinating in racial violence, marinating
in the dehumanization of your supposed racial
enemies, you know, this is an environment
that's specifically queued to get people to
snap, to radicalize, to engage in violence,
to stockpile guns.
When I have interviewed former white nationalist
and white supremacists, including folk, folks
like Frank Menck and many others of these
folks who have now become anti-racist advocates,
they almost UNILAG almost unanimously tell
the same story about how they were pulled
in, which is that they sort of found either
an attention or what they felt as support
or a community where they had an absence of
it.
Typically in their family life growing up
like that's it's almost cliche, but it's the
story they almost all tell.
Did you get any sense of at the individual
level how the folks you came across ended
up in these movements?
Yeah, I mean, particularly on the white supremacist
dating site, there was often kind of a there
was a segment, you know, in the BIOS where
people describe their politics and how they
came to be on a white supremacist dating site.
And a lot of the story started with YouTube.
There were a lot of divorces in their back
stories.
You know, there were a lot of people in the
military, you know.
I would say that the most.
Consistent theme was a sense of alienation.
Right, and I think, as we all know, that that
sense of alienation, lack of community, desire
for purpose, it crosses socioeconomic lines,
it crosses geographical divides.
You know, it's really a question of sort of
how deep is your feeling of alienation and
displacement?
And that can have a lot of different causes.
I think it's a mistake when people say, oh,
it's just toothless.
Cleatus in his mother's basement, when what
I saw was really a movement that spanned geographical
lines, socioeconomic lines is where people
with lives and sometimes spouses, sometimes
people who are in college.
You know, the myth that everyone is sort of
southern and uneducated is really a self absorbing
myth that white liberals used to say it couldn't
be anyone in my neighborhood, couldn't be
anyone in my school or my acoa, when in fact
it could.
It's just a matter of people feeling lost.
And the white supremacist white power movement
really offering you this mythos of you can
become involved, you can save the white race.
We will give you a sense of purpose in your
life.
And I think a lot of us are looking for a
sense of purpose.
A lot of us are feeling lost and alienated
and we all find that in different ways.
But that's the sort of compelling argument
they make, as is here's a chance to be part
of a community of people saving the white
race.
Yeah, what's interesting about that is, you
know, there's a similar pattern to a lot of
the people that get sucked into the cult of
Trump ism, which is believing that it will
provide solutions to problems that may well
be real, but but they get tricked about where
the solutions are.
And that seems to be kind of interesting overlap
in hearing hearing you describe it.
Yeah, I mean, I think that's true of any sort
of radicalizing movement, right?
Yeah.
Is that they look at you, look at your vulnerabilities,
look at what you're seeking and then become
that, you know, love bomb you.
Although, frankly, the tenor of conversation
is quite puerile and often very cruel.
There's not a lot of love bombing going on,
but there is a sense of like you are a warrior,
you know, there's really a regression and
to very toxic and narrow gender roles.
This this idea of kind of you will be a manly
man, a warrior for the white race and encouragement
towards survivalism, towards stocking up guns.
But really the sense of kind of propping up
embattled masculinity and making that be part
of a community that has this sort of overall,
quote unquote, noble purpose.
The book is fascinating, its culture war Lords,
My Journey into the Dark Web of White Supremacy.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Tolia Laventhol.
I so appreciate your time today.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, and the book is available on Amazon
at your local indie store, which you should
please support during the pandemic and everywhere
books are sold and it goes into great detail
about not just contemporary privacy, but The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.